This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We all know people who perpetually see the glass as half empty. They can find something wrong in every situation. The potatoes are hard, the beef is tough. I don't know. Other people have it easy. Other places are nicer. Other times were better.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们都认识这样的人，他们永远觉得杯子是半空的。他们在任何情况下都能挑出毛病。土豆太硬，牛肉太老。我不知道。别人过得都很轻松。别的地方更好。过去的好时光更美好。
I'm a grumpy old man. I don't like everything the way it is now compared to the way it used to be. These people see the world through dirt-staying glasses, and the glasses are scratched, and they were the wrong prescription anyway. Oh, and here's $65 for your budget. Oh, and here are four idiots who'll do nothing but way you down. Oh, and your your cat still dead. Researchers, counselors and motivational speakers have examined the effects of these attitudes on our relationships and well-being. Complaining is damaging to our health. It's destructive to our relationships and it limits your career success.
我是一个脾气暴躁的老头子。比起过去，我现在看什么都不顺眼。这些人透过蒙尘的眼镜看世界，眼镜上满是划痕，而且度数根本就不对。哦，这是给你的65美元预算。哦，这还有四个除了拖你后腿什么都不会的笨蛋。哦，你的猫还是死了。研究人员、心理咨询师和励志演说家都曾探讨过这些态度对我们的人际关系和幸福感的影响。抱怨对我们的健康有害。它会破坏我们的人际关系，并限制你的职业成功。
But if complaining is so bad for us, why is it so ubiquitous? Does it serve a psychological purpose? Does it have benefits? This week on Hidden Brain, the psychology of complaining. Why we do it, the effects it has on those around us, and how we can learn to complain more effectively. All of us know what it's like to be on the receiving end of unfairness. It's a source of great unhapp be on the receiving end of unfairness. It's a source of great unhappiness in the workplace and in personal relationships. At
但是，如果抱怨对我们有这么大的坏处，为什么它还无处不在？它有什么心理目的吗？它有什么好处吗？本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨抱怨的心理学。我们为什么会抱怨，它对我们周围的人有什么影响，以及我们如何学会更有效地抱怨。我们所有人都经历过遭受不公的滋味。这是职场中和人际关系中巨大不幸的根源。在
Arizona State University, Mike Bear studies how we process unfairness, what we do about it, and what we ought to do about it. Mike Bear, welcome to Hiddenbrain. Thank you for having me. Mike, I want to take you back to your days as a PhD student. I understand there was an back to your days as a PhD student. I understand there was an administrator in your program who let's say you didn't quite get along with. What did the administrator do that that wrangled you? So I was a second year PhD student in a pass-fail class
亚利桑那州立大学，迈克·贝尔研究我们如何处理不公、我们如何对此采取行动，以及我们应该如何采取行动。迈克·贝尔，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。迈克，我想把你带回你读博士的那段日子。我听说在你的项目中，有一位行政人员，怎么说呢，你和他似乎不太合得来。那个行政人员做了什么惹恼了你的事？当时我是个读博第二年的学生，正在上一门通过/不通过的课程，
that provide us with teaching tips, which I was going to start doing the following year. And one of the assignments was to give a 15-minute presentation on the topic of our choice. And that was the only instruction we were getting. So I wanted to get a head start on my teaching prep, so I wanted to present on a portion of the Trust Justice and Ethics chapter from the organizational behavior class that I would be teaching.
这门课为我们提供教学技巧，我打算第二年开始用。其中一项作业是就我们选择的主题做一个15分钟的演讲。那是我们得到的唯一的指令。所以我想在备课上抢占先机，想就我将要教授的组织行为学课程中的“信任、正义与道德”章节的一部分进行演讲。
And as the best practices, the students and faculty suggested that new teachers ask others for their teaching materials and then personalize them. So Mike went to a new assistant professor, Jessica Rodel. He explained the assignment. And she then gave me her slides which were tweaks of the slides that the textbook publisher provides to all teachers. At that point I then changed 80 to 90% of the slide content. And the only content I retained was the definitions of key terms, which matched the textbook I'd
按照最佳实践，学生和教职员工建议新老师向其他人索取教学资料，然后将其个性化。于是迈克去找了一位新任助理教授杰西卡·罗德尔。他向她解释了作业要求。然后她给了我她的幻灯片，这些幻灯片是对教科书出版商提供给所有老师的幻灯片进行了一些微调。那时我改了80%到90%的幻灯片内容。我保留的唯一内容是关键术语的定义，这与我将要教学的教科书相匹配。
be teaching from. So after we presented, the teacher pulls me aside at the end of the class. And he starts off by saying that my presentation was too good, so I must have plagiarized it. And I didn't think I'd done anything wrong, and I still don't, so I gave him the full story. He then told me this was a serious issue, and he'd talk with my advisor. So I then showed my advisor the slides that I started with,
所以在我们演讲结束后，老师在课结束时把我拉到一边。他一开始就说我的演讲太棒了，所以我肯定是抄袭的。我觉得自己没有做错任何事，现在也这么觉得，所以我把事情的前因后果都告诉了他。他接着告诉我这是一个严重的问题，他会和我的导师谈谈。于是我向我的导师展示了我最初使用的幻灯片，
as well as the slides that I presented. And he agreed that the only similarities were the definitions. And he was the author of the textbook that I was teaching from, as well as the creator of the slides. So he had from, as well as the creator of the slides. So he had some pretty strong familiarity with the content. So ultimately, my department stood up for me and the administrator dropped the issue after
以及我演讲时用的幻灯片。他同意唯一的相似之处就是那些定义。而他正是那本我用来教学的教科书的作者，也是这些幻灯片的创作者。所以他对这些内容非常熟悉。最终，我的系里支持了我，在经过了一番大张旗鼓的争论后，那位行政人员也放弃了这个问题。
a lot of huffing and puffing. But Mike found that he couldn't drop the issue. It wrangled him to have been accused of unethical behavior. And very soon, he found someone else in his corner. So because Jessica had been implicated in the same situation because she initially gave me the slides, and the administrator also wanted to talk to her about what had happened, which ended up
但迈克发现自己无法放下这个问题。被指控存在不道德行为让他感到十分恼火。很快，他发现身边站着另一个人。因为杰西卡也卷入了同一事件，因为她最初给了我幻灯片，而且那位行政人员也想找她谈谈发生的事情，这最终给她带来了麻烦。
being a hassle for her. And she was also, I don't know if the word outrage is the right level, but she was certainly upset that she was being accused of something for simply engaging in the best practices that we're told to do as PhD students. And so although the issue had technically gone away, and it wasn't a problem anymore, almost every time the Jessica and I talked, and we talked regularly to meet for research ideas, we rehashed this experience.
她也——我不知道“愤怒”这个词是否准确，但她肯定对遭到指控感到心烦意乱，因为她只是在做我们作为博士生被告知要遵循的最佳实践。所以，尽管这个问题在技术上已经消失了，不再是一个问题了，但几乎每次我和杰西卡交谈时——我们为了讨论研究想法而定期见面——我们都会反复咀嚼这段经历。
We complained about the administrator, the accusations, the hassle we'd went through, and it invariably led us to complain about other things we didn't like about this person, which was a pretty long list. And this went on for weeks. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, weeks after this, on fair experience, it would just keep coming up and keep coming up.
我们抱怨那个行政人员、那些指控、我们经历的麻烦，这不可避免地让我们开始抱怨我们不喜欢这个人的其他事情，而那是一个相当长的清单。这种情况持续了好几个星期。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景各自的不公经历过去好几个星期后，这些事情还是会不断浮现，不断被提起。
Like actors perfecting their lines, they would each rehearse their respective complaints. And the more they complained, the more they complained. We were absolutely egging one another along. I don't know if we were trying to one up each other, but we definitely wanted confirmation that we had been wronged. And so in that situation it became this opportunity for us to make sure that we were correct. And unfortunately it also made us angrier. The angrier Mike got, the colder he became, every time he was around the administrator. I really didn't have a positive attitude towards him.
就像排练台词的演员一样，他们各自反复诉说着各自的抱怨。他们越抱怨，就越发抱怨。我们简直是在互相拱火。我不知道我们是不是想在抱怨上压对方一头，但我们绝对是想从对方那里得到确认：我们确实受到了不公对待。所以在那种情况下，这就变成了一个机会，让我们确保自己的做法是正确的。但不幸的是，这也让我们更加愤怒。迈克越生气，当他靠近那个行政人员时，他的态度就越冷漠。我对他的确没有什么积极的态度。
I never said anything rude, I never did anything that way, but there was definitely this distancing. It was happening, and I certainly wasn't doing a great job hiding my emotions. And it was something that he noticed. Mike's view of the administrator narrowed. With his tunnel vision, he could see nothing good about this person, nothing of value. It was only in retrospect that he realized his anger probably kept him
我从没说过粗话，也没做出什么出格的事，但那种疏离感确实是存在的。这种疏离正在发生，而且我显然也没有很好地掩饰自己的情绪。那是他注意到的事情。迈克对那个行政人员的看法变得狭隘了。带着这种管窥之见，他看不到这个人任何好的一面，看不到任何价值。直到事后回想，他才意识到自己的愤怒可能让他
from getting the administrator's help on important matters and kept him from learning from a senior scholar. This person, it was a member of our department and they were also the associate dean over allocations of PhD student office space, funding, travel. This person was also a very accomplished researcher and there might have been opportunities to collaborate with them on effective research projects. And so it's hard to know what was going through in his mind, but certainly he would sense my dislike. You know, I'm thinking Mike as you're talking that what would happen to you in this micro instance
错失了在重要事情上寻求该行政人员帮助的机会，也让他错失了一位资深学者的教导。这个人不仅是我们系的成员，还是负责分配博士生办公空间、资金和差旅的副院长。这个人也是一位非常有成就的研究人员，本来可能还有机会与他们在高效的研究项目上进行合作。所以很难知道他当时在想什么，但他肯定能感觉到我对他的厌恶。你知道，迈克，听你这么说，我想着你在微观层面经历的事情，
is now happening actually on a much more macro scale. You know, when I think about social media platforms now, I feel like there are some platforms that are almost entirely devoted to the art of complaining and to getting, to receiving solidarity from other people in the, in the accuracy or the legitimacy of your complaints. Can you talk about that idea for a moment that what used to be I'm unhappy with someone, so I talk to someone else about it,
现在实际上正以更大的宏观规模发生着。你知道，当我想到现在的社交媒体平台时，我觉得有些平台几乎完全致力于抱怨的艺术，并致力于获得、接受其他人对你抱怨的准确性或合理性的声援。你能谈谈那个想法一会儿吗？过去那种我对某人不满意，所以我找别人谈论这事，
I receive sort of interpersonal solidarity as I'm doing it. This is what you and Jessica were doing. Has now become something that actually is multiplied on a much larger scale, where people are expressing complaints and expecting in some ways to get reinforcements from others. We want people to agree with us. There was an experience I had where there was a funding decision that was made by our department head a couple years ago, and I disagreed with it.
我在这样做时得到了某种人际声援。这就是你和杰西卡一直在做的事。现在已经变成了一种在更大规模上被成倍放大事情，人们在表达抱怨，并在某种程度上期待从他人那里获得声援。我们希望别人同意我们的观点。几年前，我经历过一件事，当时我们系主任做了一个资金分配决定，我并不同意。
And so I texted a friend who was outside of my department to complain about it. And his response was to point out that maybe I had seen the situation differently, and maybe the department head was trying to make sure that the needs of multiple people within the department were met. Well, that wasn't what I wanted to hear.
于是我给一个系外的朋友发信息抱怨这件事。他的反应是指出，也许我对局势的看法不同，也许系主任是想确保系里多方人员的需求都能得到满足。好吧，这可不是我想听到的。
I wanted somebody to agree with me that I had been wrong. And so I stopped that text chain and texted another person within my department. And the situation repeated itself. He suggested that perhaps I was mistaken and I might want wanna think about it differently and that things would work out. Again, I thought, don't these people realize
我希望有人同意我的观点，承认我受了委屈。所以我停下了那个聊天框，给系里的另一个人发了信息。结果情况重演了。他暗示也许是我弄错了，我可能想换个角度考虑，事情总会解决的。我再次心想，难道这些人没有意识到
what I'm looking for here? And so I texted the third person, and this person agreed, yeah, you were definitely screwed in that situation, and I thought, victory, I got what I wanted. Now, after five minutes, I went, oh, I have been an idiot here. And I realized that what I really needed was to hear people reframe the situation and
我在这里寻找的是什么吗？于是我给第三个人发了信息，这个人同意了，对啊，你在那种情况下绝对是被坑了，我想，太好了，我得到了我想要的。然而五分钟后，我觉得，噢，我刚才真是个白痴。我意识到我真正需要的是听别人重新构建局势，
point out to me that I was perhaps mistaken, there was another way to look at it. But we have this inherent desire to want to be agreed with when something bad happens to us. And that's how we get in these echo chambers in these social media platforms, where we avoid areas where we'll hear something that suggests there's another way to look at the situation. I want to flag that when we reach out to others for commissaration, and we're basically getting
并向我指出我可能错了，还有另一种看待问题的方式。但当不好的事情发生在我们身上时，我们内心深处有一种渴望，希望别人能同意我们的观点。这就是我们陷入这些社交媒体平台的迴音室的原因，在那里我们避开那些会听到暗示有另一种方式看待局势的言论的区域。我想指出的是，当我们向他人寻求同情时，我们基本上是在让
one others to agree with us. Invariably, this involves something negative that we're saying about a third party. We rarely reach out to seek commissaration when we have something positive to say about a third party. The net effect of this, whether that's on an individual interpersonal level or whether it's on a global level on a social media platform, is that the amount of negativity that's then being shared is amplified just because we selectively focus on the negative rather than the positive. Can you talk about this idea that this has in some ways a corrosive effect because it's not like we're sharing all the things that are happening to us.
彼此意见一致。这不可避免地涉及到我们对第三方所说的一些负面言论。当我们对第三方有积极的评价时，我们很少去寻求同情。这种做法的净效应，无论是对个人人际层面，还是对社交媒体平台上的全球层面，都是被分享的负面情绪的数量被放大了，仅仅因为我们有选择地关注负面情绪而不是积极情绪。你能谈谈这个想法吗？这在某种程度上具有腐蚀作用，因为这并不像我们在分享发生在我们身上的所有事情。
We're selectively sharing the things that are negative. It's a great insight. With my MBA students, I frequently ask, who here has more positive interactions with their supervisor than negative ones? And basically everybody in the class raises their hand. And then I ask who would agree that more than 90% of your interactions with your supervisor are positive. Again, most of the class raises their hand.
我们是有选择地分享那些消极的事情。这是一个很好的见解。在我的MBA学生中，我经常问，在座谁与主管的积极互动比消极互动多？基本上全班都举手了。然后我问，谁会同意你们与主管90%以上的互动都是积极的？同样，全班大部分人也举手了。
Except that's not what we talk about when people say what was your day like. We focus on the 5% or 10% of our day that was negative or when we were treated unfairly. And it gives a bias picture to other people and to ourselves of what our day was like and even what our supervisors are like. And it can help to remember that supervisors aren't perfect. And if you're a supervisor, you're not going to be perfect. They're invariably will be these negative interactions. But when we are focused on the unfairness experiences
但当人们谈论“你今天过得怎么样”时，我们谈论的并不是这些。我们关注的是一天中那5%或10%消极的时刻，或者我们受到不公正对待的时刻。这给其他人以及我们自己留下了一种有偏差的画面，让我们觉得我们的一天是怎样的，甚至让我们觉得主管是怎样的。记住主管并非完美会对我们有所帮助。如果你是主管，你也不可能十全十美。这些消极的互动不可避免地会发生。但当我们专注于不公的经历，
rather than the fairness, it's almost in our mind that we start to think that our supervisors are more unfair than they actually are. our mind that we start to think that our supervisors are more unfair than they actually are. Chances are you've experienced this yourself. Maybe your boss tells you to stay late one day. You complain to a coworker and feel a sense of relief. The next time you're bossed as something frustrating, you vent again. And again, it feels good to complain about our negative experiences, and most of us do it without giving it any thought. That's what Mike and Jessica did for weeks
而不是公平的经历时，我们的脑海里几乎开始觉得我们的主管比实际情况更不公正。你很可能自己也经历过这种事。也许有一天你的老板让你加班。你向同事抱怨并感到一阵解脱。下次你老板再做出一件令人沮丧的事时，你又开始宣泄了。再一次，抱怨我们的负面感觉感觉很好，我们大多数人在这样做时都没有多想。这就是迈克和杰西卡在与行政人员发生不愉快互动后数周内一直在做的事情。然后，有一天，他们灵光一现。有一天我们坐下来时，这大概是事情发生后的大约四周，那个行政人员又被提起了。他做了一件以不同方式影响了该系和杰西卡的事情。当我们开始抱怨时，我们几乎在同一时间看着对方，停下来并说道：“这毫无用处，对吧？”我们接下来的想法是：“这会是一个很好的研究项目。”我认为你刚才几分钟一直在告诉我的内容中，有一个潜台词是第二个想法。
after the bad interaction with the administrator. And then, one day, they had a flash of epiphany. One day when we sat down, this was probably about four weeks after this had happened, the administrator came up again. He had done something that affected the department and Jessica in a different way. And as we started to complain, we almost at the same time looked at each other, stopped and said, this isn't helping, is it? And our next thought was, this would make a great research project. There's a second idea that I think is a subtext for what you've been telling me the
在与管理员进行那次糟糕的互动之后。然后，有一天，他们突然顿悟了。有一天，当我们坐下来时，这大概是事情发生四周后，管理员又出现了。他做了一件以不同方式影响部门和杰西卡的事情。当我们开始抱怨时，我们几乎同时看着对方，停下来并说，这没用，对吧？我们的下一个想法是，这将是一个很棒的研究项目。我认为这是你一直在告诉我的一些内容的潜台词的第二个想法
last few minutes. And it's a really important subtext to draw attention to because it's so intuitively obvious that I think we don't stop to think about it, which is most of us actually believe that talking to someone else about the things that upset us is a good thing. And most of the people we talk with, they believe that us talking to them is also a good thing. Can you just talk about this idea that there's a widespread intuitive belief that talking helps? Absolutely. In fact, that is what prompted this research study, is we dug into the literature In fact, that is what prompted this research study, is we dug into the literature and almost all of it suggests that talking about our negative feelings or bad things that have happened
这是一个非常重要的、需要引起注意的潜台词，因为它是如此直观、显而易见，以至于我认为我们没有停下来去思考它，那就是我们大多数人都真正相信，与他人谈论让我们心烦的事情是一件好事。而我们与之交谈的大多数人，他们也相信我们对他们倾诉是一件好事。你能谈谈这种普遍存在的直觉信念——倾诉有帮助——吗？当然。事实上，正是这一点促成了这项研究，我们深入查阅了文献，
to us helps us. But as we dug deeper, we realized that most of this research looks at how people reported that they felt immediately after the event. And there are studies that show up between 80 and 90% believe that the experience helped and that they would do it again. The research would also look at what are the emotions in the five minutes after sharing that experience. And often what we focus on when we think,
几乎所有的文献都表明，谈论我们的负面情绪或发生在我们身上的坏事对我们是有帮助的。但随着我们深入研究，我们意识到大部分此类研究关注的是人们在事件发生后立即报告他们的感受。有研究表明，80%到90%的人认为这种经历有帮助，并且他们会再次这样做。该研究还会探讨分享经历后五分钟内的情绪是怎样的。通常当我们认为
oh, it helped is because we're thinking about the fact that my relationship with the listener got better. And it does. It improves our relationship to feel that we are supported and that we are listened to. But there's another party in this equation that gets ignored and that is the supervisor, which is why we wanted to dig more into our people
“哦，这有帮助”时，我们关注的是我和听众的关系变好了这一事实。确实如此。感觉到自己得到支持和倾听确实能改善我们的人际关系。但这个等式中还有另一方被忽视了，那就是主管，这就是为什么我们想深入了解人们是否
actually harming themselves in terms of that relationship with the boss and their workout comes and trading that away for this momentary feeling of, oh, I get a little bit of relief and I feel like somebody agrees with me. Do the short term emotional benefits of complaining detract from long term well-being? And as we listen sympathetically when others complain to us, are we actually helping or hurting?
实际上在损害他们与老板的关系以及他们的工作成果，却用这种暂时的感觉——“哦，我得到了点解脱，我觉得有人同意我的观点”——来交换这种损害？抱怨带来的短期情感好处会损害长期的幸福感吗？当我们带着同理心倾听别人的抱怨时，我们到底是在帮倒忙还是在帮忙？
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Complaining can be cathartic. It can also be fun. It's a way for us to express how we feel and to get others to back us up. Social media has amplified our avenues to complain. You could argue there are entire social media platforms that are principally devoted to complaining. Most of us have a positive view of sharing our concerns with others. We think it allows us to speak up, fight back, stand up for ourselves.
你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。抱怨可以起到宣泄作用。它也可以很有趣。这是我们表达感受并让别人支持我们的一种方式。社交媒体放大了我们抱怨的途径。你可以说，有些社交媒体平台完全是为了抱怨而设立的。我们大多数人对与他人分享我们的担忧持积极态度。我们认为这能让我们大声疾呼、进行反击、为自己挺身而出。
At Arizona State University, Mike Bear believed those things too. Then he started looking at the data. Mike Bear believed those things too. Then he started looking at the data. Mike, you conducted a study on bus drivers in London asking about their workplace complaints. Can you tell me what kind of complaints they told you they had about their supervisors? A lot of their complaints focused on how they felt that the supervisors would take
在亚利桑那州立大学，迈克·贝尔也曾坚信这些。然后他开始查看数据。迈克·贝尔也曾坚信这些。然后他开始查看数据。迈克，你对伦敦的公交车司机进行了一项研究，询问了他们在职场上的抱怨。你能告诉我他们对主管有哪些抱怨吗？他们的很多抱怨都集中在他们觉得在有投诉时，主管会站在
the customer's side in when there was a complaint. So one driver remarked, we're treated with contempt. The customer is not always right. We have several managerial staff who can't even drive a car, let alone a bus, try and tell us how to do our job. I've been doing this job for almost 15 years and never had an accident of any kind. I never take time off work,
乘客一边。所以一位司机评论道：“我们受到的对待充满蔑视。顾客并不总是对的。我们有几个管理人员连汽车都不会开，更别提公交车了，却试图告诉我们如何工作。我干这行快15年了，从来没有发生过任何事故。我从不请假旷工，
but this is never taken into account. But if I look at someone's sideways, I get called into the manager. I need to get this off my chest. I'm doing it now, and I'll share this with other drivers who I value. Like many research projects, this one got started as a result of chance.
但这从来没有被考虑在内。但如果我对别人斜视了一眼，我就会被叫去见经理。我必须把这些压抑的情绪吐露出来。我现在就在这样做，我也会把这些分享给那些我重视的其他司机。”像许多研究项目一样，这个项目也是偶然开始的。
One of Mike's co-authors was working with him on a project looking at trust. She was hanging out at a bus depot in Britain and got to overhearing the bus drivers talk. She just sat and listened to the bus drivers and the experience that they have. And she came back to us and she marked, this is an interesting group. They like to winjen complain most constantly while they're in the depots to each other over lunch or breaks or shift changes. And this comment came at a time when Jessica and I were thinking about doing this research project on fairness talk. And we thought this is perfect. And so having been prompted and realizing that this was an environment or workplace where
迈克的一位合著者当时正和他合作一个关于信任的项目。她在英国的一个公交车场闲逛时，无意中听到了公交车司机们的谈话。她只是坐在那里听公交车司机们谈论他们的经历。她回来后对我们说：“这是一个有趣的群体。他们在车场里吃午饭、休息或换班时，总是对彼此唠叨、抱怨个不停。”这个评论发表的时候，杰西卡和我正考虑做这个关于公平对话的研究项目。我们觉得这太完美了。所以受到启发后，并意识到这是一个
complaining was very common, we thought let's switch and focus on looking at these bus drivers and the effect of their complaining to their co-workers. You know, as you were talking just now, I was trying to count up the number of different workplaces I've been working at, Mike, over the years, and I count five different workplaces before my current job. And I feel like at every one of those workplaces, there were just these elaborate rituals where people would complain about the managers. And it was almost an art form in some of the workplaces that I was at, where people would
抱怨非常普遍的环境或工作场所，我们决定把重点转向这些公交车司机以及他们向同事抱怨的影响。你知道，迈克，刚才听你说话时，我一直在数我这些年来在多少个不同的工作场所工作过，在我现在的工作之前，我算了一下有五个不同的工作场所。我觉得在每一个工作场所里，都有这样一套精心编排的仪式，人们会抱怨经理。在我呆过的一些工作场所里，这几乎成了一种艺术形式，人们会
describe in really elaborate ways, all the ways in which their managers did something wrong. So what the bus drivers were doing in London is hardly an aberration or hardly unique. I've had the exact same experience. It's almost like a right of passage that this is how we build relationships with our co-workers. Oh, did you get screwed over by the boss? Me too. Let me tell you about it.
用非常精心的方式，描述他们的经理做错了的所有事情。所以伦敦的公交车司机们所做的事情绝不是反常的，也绝不是独一无二的。我有过完全相同的经历。这几乎就像是一个成人礼，这就是我们与同事建立关系的方式。哦，你被老板坑了吗？我也是。让我跟你讲讲。
And we bond over these negative experiences. Almost I had a friend who was in the military. He was in the Navy and he worked on a submarine. And he said that the people who would not complain about the boss were ostracized. They weren't part of the group if they wouldn't get involved in these complaining situations. And so I can imagine a situation in which you may not actually agree that the supervisor has been unfair, but you don't want to be the part of the out group in that situation.
我们因这些负面经历而建立联系。我有一个朋友曾在军队服役。他在海军工作，在一艘潜水艇上工作。他说那些不抱怨老板的人会被排挤。如果不参与这些抱怨的情况，他们就不是集体的一员。所以我想象得出这样一种情况：你可能并不真的同意主管是不公平的，但你又不想在那种情况下成为被排挤的局外人。
You want to be pulling yourself into that in group. So you have this group of employees who have complaints about their supervisors and it's what's stipulating here, of course, that some of these complaints might have been entirely legitimate. They might indeed have been supervisors who are acting in abusive ways or disrespectful ways. But you followed these employees over time and what were you hoping to measure? What were you looking to measure about their mental health or their well-being?
你会想把自己拉进那个核心圈子。所以你有一群对主管有抱怨的员工，这里所假定的是，当然，其中一些抱怨可能完全是合法的。他们确实可能是那些表现出虐待或不尊重行为的主管。但你长期追踪了这些员工，你希望衡量什么？你希望衡量他们心理健康或幸福感的哪些方面？
So we first measured the extent to which they talked to their co-workers about unfair experiences. Then six weeks later, we came back and we measured the extent to which they felt anger towards their supervisor or when they thought about their relationship with their supervisor that they felt hope. At this same time, we also measured the extent to which they sensed a feeling of forgiveness toward their supervisor for any unfairness that might have happened.
所以我们首先测量了他们向同事谈论不公平经历的程度。然后六周后，我们回来测量了他们对主管感到愤怒的程度，或者当他们想到与主管的关系时他们感到希望的程度。与此同时，我们还测量了他们对主管因可能发生的任何不公平待遇而感到的宽恕感。
Then several weeks later, we looked at supervisors' ratings of the extent to which these employees went out of their way to help them, to do extra work, to volunteer. And this is all voluntary work. That's what we look at called citizenship behavior. And it's a way to look at whether the relationship between employee and supervisor is strong. If you like and have a good relationship, you tend to help. And if you don't, you tend not to help. And the reason we looked at anger and hope is that anger stems from an appraisal that somebody has hindered my goal achievement
然后又过了几周，我们观察了主管对这些员工为他们付出额外努力、做额外工作、做志愿者的程度的评分。这全都是志愿工作。这就是我们所说的公民行为。这是检验员工与主管之间关系是否牢固的一种方法。如果你喜欢并与某人关系良好，你往往会伸出援手。如果你不喜欢，你往往不会帮忙。我们之所以观察愤怒和希望，是因为愤怒源于这样一种评估：有人阻碍了我的目标实现
and that they are to blame. And hope is this belief that although there is a situation that is negative, I think that it can be fixed. I'm willing to move forward. It's an approach emotion. Whereas anger, the tendency when we feel anger is to attack. Now at work, employees are unlikely to overtly attack the supervisor, but a more subtle way to do that is by distancing themselves. And you kind of get back by not going above and beyond. What did you
并且他们应当为此负责。而希望则是一种信念，即尽管情况是消极的，但我认为它是可以解决的。我愿意继续前进。这是一种趋近情绪。而愤怒则不同，当我们感到愤怒时，往往会选择攻击。现在在工作中，员工不太可能会公开攻击主管，但一个更微妙的做法是与他们保持距离。而你通过不超越本职工作来回击。你在
find in terms of the effects of complaining on hope and anger and forgiveness? We found that those employees as on fairness talk went up, that their feelings of anger also went up, and their feelings of hope went down. Now, the importance of that is as anger went up, forgiveness went down. And as hope goes up, forgiveness goes up, but because hope was decreasing, it was also decreasing the amount of forgiveness. So ultimately, we found that the more that employees
希望、愤怒和宽恕方面发现了关于抱怨的什么影响？我们发现，随着员工不公平对话的增多，他们的愤怒情绪也在增加，而希望情绪则在下降。这其中的重要性在于，随着愤怒增加，宽恕减少了；随着希望增加，宽恕也会增加，但由于希望在减少，宽恕的量也在减少。因此最终我们发现，员工越是
talked about unfairness, the less likely they were to forgive the supervisor for any unfair actions. Why do you think this was happening, Mike? Because again, at an intuitive level, it feels there's the old problem. A problem shared is a problem halved. The idea that when we share our problems, they are reduced. Why do you think that was not happening here? When you share a sense of unfairness, to some extent, you are looking for them to confirm your interpretation of the event. At the moment, you're not really sure whether or not it was unfair or not. You're not sure whether there is a solution or a way forward.
谈论不公，他们就越不可能原谅主管的任何不公平行为。迈克，你认为为什么会这样？因为再次从直觉层面上讲，似乎有一个老问题。分担的问题就减半了。这种观点认为，当我们分享问题时，问题就会减轻。你认为为什么这里没有发生这种情况？当你分享不公正感时，在某种程度上，你是在寻找他们来证实你对事件的解释。当时，你并不十分确定这到底算不算不公正。你不确定是否存在解决方案或前进的道路。
The more you talk about it, you're rehashing that event. It's making those negative feelings come to the forefront. Every time you talk about it, you're reliving the fact that someone treated you negatively. And so, let's say you don't talk about the unfair event. Well, after a period of four, five, six weeks, it may have receded into the background. But if you have continually brought that up and rehashed that event, it's fresh in your mind almost as if it happened yesterday. So you found that the extent of complaining was a strong predictor of the increase in anger
你越是谈论它，你就是在反复咀嚼那个事件。这会让那些负面情绪浮出水面。每次你谈论它，你就是在重温有人对你进行消极对待的事实。所以，假设你没有谈论这个不公正的事件。好吧，经过四、五、六周的时间，它可能已经淡出背景了。但如果你不断地提起并反复咀嚼那个事件，它在你的脑海里就会像昨天刚发生一样新鲜。所以你发现抱怨的程度是愤怒增加
and a decrease in hope. What did you find in terms of the effects of complaining on people being goods to goods and citizens in their workplace. So we found that as forgiveness went down, so did employees' willingness to be good citizens within the workplace. They volunteered to help those supervisors less. And this was observed behavior from the supervisors. They didn't know that we were investigating unfairness, they didn't know that we were investigating the extent to which their employees were forgiving them. All that they were doing was raiding the employees' behaviors. And we found a strong correlation between employees' unwillingness to forgive the supervisors
和希望减少的强有力预测指标。在人们成为职场好公民的效果方面，你发现了什么？我们发现，随着宽恕减少，员工在职场中做好公民的意愿也在减少。他们更少自愿帮助那些主管。这是主管们观察到的行为。他们不知道我们在调查不公，他们也不知道我们在调查员工原谅他们的程度。他们所做的只是对员工的行为进行评分。我们发现，员工不愿原谅主管的意愿
and a decrease in their citizenship behavior. I mean, in some ways this has parallels with the story that you told about the time when you were in a PhD program, Mike. I mean, the experience you had with your administrator almost eerily parallels exactly what happened with the London bus drivers. Exactly right. I think most of the time, we don't even realize that we are distancing ourselves from others to whom we have negative feelings.
与公民行为的减少之间存在强烈的相关性。我的意思是，在某些方面，这与你讲的你在读博时期的故事有相似之处，迈克。我的意思是，你与行政人员的经历几乎诡异地与伦敦公交车司机身上发生的事情完全平行。完全正确。我想大多数时候，我们甚至没有意识到我们正在与那些让我们产生负面情绪的人保持距离。
If you told employees that they're distancing and lack of forgiveness was actually hurting their performance ratings, they would probably be surprised. They would probably think, oh, my supervisor doesn't realize that I'm distancing myself or I'm mad. I do a great job hiding it, but we actually do a very bad job
如果你告诉员工，他们的疏离和缺乏宽恕实际上正在损害他们的绩效评分，他们可能会感到惊讶。他们可能会想：“哦，我的主管没有意识到我在疏离或者我在生气。我把情绪隐藏得很好”，但实际上我们在
of hiding our emotions towards the people around us. When we harbor negative emotions or we don't think that that relationship can improve, we are going to invariably pull back from that relationship. So there's a paradox here, Mike, which is on the one hand, if something wrong happens to us, if someone treats us badly, if someone behaves abusively towards us, it seems really problematic to say, don't talk about this to anyone, don't share any of this with anyone, keep it to yourself in five weeks, you're going to forget it.
向周围人隐藏情绪这件事上做得很差。当我们怀恨在心或者认为关系无法改善时，我们不可避免地会从这段关系中抽身。所以这里有一个悖论，迈克，一方面，如果有什么不好的事情发生在我们身上，如果有人粗暴对待我们，如果有人对我们采取虐待行为，说“不要跟任何人谈论这件事，不要跟任何人分享，把它憋在心里，五周后你就会忘记它”似乎真的很有问题。
I mean, that doesn't seem like very healthy advice. On the other hand, you're also saying that when we talk about it with others and complain about it to others, it often doesn't lead to very good positive outcomes. Is there a solution to this paradox to this conundrum? That's a great insight, because we would never suggest that you shouldn't talk about bad things that have happened certainly when they rise to the level of abuse. So the solution here is who are you talking to? And our natural inclination is to talk to people who agree with us, who commiserate with us, who point out that we were wrong. But we also in this
我的意思是，这听起来不像是很健康的建议。另一方面，你又说，当我们与他人谈论并在其他人面前抱怨时，它往往不会带来很好的积极结果。有没有解决这个悖论、这个难题的办法？这是一个很好的见解，因为我们绝不会建议你不应该谈论已经发生的不好的事情，特别是当它们上升到虐待的程度时。所以这里的解决方法是：你在跟谁说话？而我们的自然倾向是找那些同意我们观点、同情我们、指出我们受了委屈的人倾诉。但我们在这项
study and another experiment, we looked at to what extent does the listener impact our outcomes with the supervisor. And what we found is when you talk to someone who reframes the situation, who points out that there are solutions, who suggests that maybe you should look at it from the supervisor's perspective, that the positive effect on anger and the negative effect on hope, those go away.
研究以及另一个实验中也探讨了：倾听者在多大程度上影响了我们与主管的结果。我们发现，当你与一个重新建构局势、指出有解决方案、暗示也许你应该从主管角度来看待问题的人交谈时，对愤怒的积极影响和对希望的消极影响就会消失。
And so essentially having someone tell you that there are solutions to your problem gets rid of the negative effects of talking about unfairness. Just to take you back to the example that you gave me, Mike, when you went to Jessica, and let's say you told Jessica about the problem you were having with your administrator, what would have been the response that she could have given you that in some ways might have led to a more positive outcome for you and for Jessica and perhaps for the administrator as well? In that situation, I think it would have been helpful for Jessica to point out the importance of having a good relationship with that administrator,
所以，基本上，让某人告诉你你的问题有解决办法，就能消除谈论不公带来的负面影响。迈克，带回到你之前给我的那个例子，当你去找杰西卡时，比方说你向杰西卡讲述了你和行政人员遇到的问题，她本可以给出什么回应，在某种程度上可能会为你、为杰西卡，甚至可能为那位行政人员带来更积极的结果？在这种情况下，我认为杰西卡指出与那位行政人员保持良好关系的重要性，
of pointing out all the different ways in which they would affect my PhD career. And pointing out that ensuring a good relationship with that administrator would ultimately be helpful to me. It would also have been helpful to hear that things had the possibility of getting better. That this was an isolated situation that perhaps the administrator saw it in this particular way and after having it discussed with them, perhaps they would see my side of the story. So there's again something of a paradox here, Mike, which is that when we reach out to others for help, we're actually not looking for someone to reframe the problem for us.
指出他们会以各种不同方式影响我的博士生涯，并指出确保与那位行政人员保持良好关系最终对我会有帮助，这些都会很有帮助。听到事情有变好的可能性，听到这只是一次孤立事件，也许行政人员只是以这种特定方式看待它，但在讨论过后，也许他会看到我这边的故事，这些也会很有帮助。所以这里再次存在某种悖论，迈克，那就是当我们向他人寻求帮助时，我们其实并不是在找人帮我们重新构建问题。
As you yourself mentioned some time ago, when you had a problem and you found someone who tried to reframe the problem to you, you promptly ended the text chain and went to somebody else who basically reinforced what it is that you wanted to hear. Can you talk a little bit about what reframing actually is doing? Is it merely a strategic tactic to tell us, you know, this is not the smart thing to do? What is the purpose of reframing, do you think? Well, we focused on reframing is the other person helping us see the bigger picture. To see the other person's side, to see why they acted the way they did or why they thought
正如你不久前自己提到的，当你遇到问题并找到了一个试图为你重新构建问题的人时，你立马结束了短信对话，去找了另一个基本上在强化你想听到的话的人。你能稍微谈谈重新构建实际上在做什么吗？它仅仅是一种战略策略，告诉我们“你知道，这不是明智的做法”吗？你认为重新构建的目的是什么？我们关注的重新构建是另一个人帮助我们看到更大的格局。看到对方的一面，了解他们为什么会那样做，或者为什么他们会那样思考，
the way they did or why they made a particular decision. An example I have that illustrates this is my first job out of high school was construction. And I was framing houses and it was a hard job. I didn't know what I was doing. I was lifting wood all day. It was 100 plus degrees. And the work didn't slow down to teach me these skills. And the first week on the job, I shot myself in the thumb with a nail gun. degrees and the work didn't slow down to teach me these skills. And the first week on the job, I shot myself in the thumb with a nail gun.
或者他们为什么做出某个决定。我有一个能说明这一点的例子，我高中毕业后的第一份工作是建筑业。我在给房屋做框架，那是一份艰苦的工作。我不知道自己在干什么。我整天都在搬运木头。气温高达100华氏度以上。工作并没有放慢节奏来教我这些技能。入职的第一周，我就用钉枪射中了自已的大拇指。气温高达100多度，工作并没有放慢节奏来教我这些技能。入职的第一周，我就用钉枪射中了自已的大拇指。
Oh my God. And my boss came over and he looked at it. He handed me a roll of duct tape, told me to tape it up, and we got back to work. And after about a week of this, I thought, man, I can't do this. Boss doesn't care. The boss is being unfair. The boss isn't looking at what I need. And so I called my dad and I started complaining.
天哪。然后我的老板走过来看了看。他递给我一卷胶带，让我把它粘上，我们就回去继续工作了。在这样过了一个星期之后，我想，天哪，我做不下去了。老板根本不在乎。老板太不公平了。老板根本没有考虑我的需求。于是我给爸爸打电话，开始抱怨。
And he listened to me fairly silently for about five minutes. And then he stopped me and he said, are you going to quit? And I said, no, I need this job. I want to be a construction manager. And I also need the money. And he said, then stop complaining and figure it out. And I learned two important lessons that day. One, don't go to my dad for emotional support. And two, if the situation was going to get better, it was up to me. And here I was complaining about this boss being unfair.
他默默地听了我大约五分钟。然后他打断我问：“你要辞职吗？”我说：“不，我需要这份工作。我想成为一名施工经理。而且我也需要钱。”他说：“那就别抱怨了，想办法解决。”那天我吸取了两个重要的教训。第一，不要找我爸爸寻求情感支持。第二，如果情况要变好，只能靠我自己。而当时我还在抱怨这个老板不公平。
Instead of looking at this boss had deadlines, this was my job. This is what I was getting paid for. And when he said that, my whole mentality flipped. And I stopped seeing the experience as unfair. I stopped seeing the boss as unfair. And I saw it as an opportunity. And it completely changed my mentality as I went to work and how I reacted with that supervisor. And that supervisor ended up being one of my best friends, and we actually became business
我本该看到老板有截止日期要赶，而这是我的工作，这是我拿薪水的原因。当他说完这句话时，我的整个心态都彻底转变了。我不再把这段经历看作是不公平的。我不再把老板看作是不公平的。我把它看作是一个机会。这彻底改变了我的工作心态，以及我与那位主管的相处方式。而那位主管最终成了我最好的朋友之一，我们甚至成为了商业
partners and went off and started our own construction company together. And I can look back and point to the day and the phone call of when that relationship improved, and it was because my dad gave me a reframing response, even though I thought I wanted an agreement. The takeaway when I talk to people about unfairness is not that they shouldn't complain, is they should be very selective about who they complain to. Our advice is that people should go out and search for people who perhaps have the courage to reframe when we're complaining to them. They will help us to see the bigger picture who don't just agree that we've been wronged.
伙伴，一起出去创办了自己的建筑公司。回想起来，我能指出那段关系改善的具体日子和那通电话，原因就是我爸爸给了我一个重新构架的回应，尽管当时我以为自己只是想要得到他的认同。当我与人们谈论不公感时，我的核心结论并不是他们不应该抱怨，而是他们应该非常慎重地选择向谁抱怨。我们的建议是，人们应该去找那些在我们需要倾诉时，敢于帮我们重新构架问题的人。他们会帮助我们看清全局，而不是一味附和我们的委屈。
There certainly are situations in which we have been wronged. But even in those situations, seeing the bigger picture and helping understand what we can do to move forward will invariably be helpful. There's a tension here, Mike, between what I think makes short term emotional sense for us and what might make long term emotional sense for us. And that's the picture I'm really gathering from this research, which is on a short term basis. I am looking for agreement, commissaration, and perhaps most importantly validation.
当然，确实存在我们受到委屈的情况。但即使在那种情况下，看清全局并弄清楚我们能做些什么来推动事情进展，也总是会有帮助的。迈克，这里存在一种张力：一方面是我们认为在短期内在情感上对我们合理的事情，另一方面是可能在长期内在情感上对我们更有利的事情。这正是我从这项研究中真正看到的现象，那就是在短期内，我寻求的是认同、同情，或许也是最重要的——验证。
From a long-term perspective, my emotional health might be better served by someone who says, here's the bigger picture, here's one way of thinking about it that you didn't consider before. Think about the long view. Are these two points of view and tension with one another? I think they are a bit intention. If I was speaking to listeners and people who are responding to somebody complaining about unfairness, I would suggest that they start with some level of agreement to indicating to the person who's complaining that there are elements that were unfair of what they're talking about. But I would also advise them not to get stuck on those experiences.
从长远来看，如果有人对我说“这是全局，这是你之前没考虑过的一种思考方式”，我的心理健康可能会因此得到更好的照顾。想想长远吧。这两种观点之间是否存在张力？我认为它们确实存在一定张力。如果我是对听众以及那些面对别人抱怨不公时作出反应的人说话，我会建议他们先表现出某种程度的认同，向抱怨者表明他们所谈论的事情中确实存在不公的成分。但我也建议他们不要深陷于那些经历中。
I would encourage them to shift rather quickly from, you know you're right, the boss was terrible, to, have you thought about ways of moving forward. Have you thought about how you might fix the situation? Have you thought about your role and what you could have done better? And if you're able to find somebody who can do that effectively, you're getting that validation while also getting that helpful advice that allows you to move on from that negative situation. Now that requires a lot of skill from the listener, of course. But I've certainly been able to find those people in my own life,
我鼓励他们迅速从“你知道你是对的，老板太糟糕了”转变到“你有没有想过如何向前推进？你有没有想过怎么解决这个情况？你有没有想过你的角色以及你可以做得更好的地方？”如果你能找到一个能有效地做到这一点的人，你既能获得认可，又能得到有用的建议，从而摆脱那种负面的处境。当然，这需要倾听者具备很高的技巧。不过，我在自己的生活中确实找到了这样的人，
which has required me to actively go out and search people who don't just agree with me. So, Mike, I'm wondering, you've done all this research that basically has analyzed the effects of complaining and how we can complain better and how we can find people in some ways who can help us reframe our complaints to the positive. I'm wondering if you've actually taken this advice to heart yourself. Can you think of a time in your life when you've come up with something or someone has really bothered you or done something that's really upset you? And you've managed to find people who don't merely mirror how you're feeling, but actually help you see the bigger picture? Absolutely. This happened just about a month ago. I was working on a research
这需要我主动去寻找那些不只是一味附和自己的人。所以，迈克，我想知道，你做了所有这些研究，基本上分析了抱怨的影响，以及我们如何才能更好地抱怨，以及我们如何在某种程度上找到能帮我们把抱怨转化为积极重新构架的人。我想知道你是否真的把这个建议记在心里了？你能想起生活中的什么时候，有什么人或什么事真的惹恼了你，或者做了让你非常心烦的事，而你成功找到了不会一味附和你的感受、而是真正帮你看到全局的人吗？当然有。这大约在一个月前刚刚发生。我当时在做一项研究
project that we had submitted to a journal and we had gotten back the reviews from the editor and the reviewers, and we got a Revising Resubmit. A Revising Resubmit is instructions from an editor and reviewers who tell us the changes they would like to me made to the paper. And if you make these changes, they will then review it again and decide whether or not the paper has reached the level of quality and interest for the readers of that journal. And as part of this revise and recent, met one of the reviewers had made some comments that I didn't agree with. And to indicate
项目，我们把它投给了一家期刊，然后收到了编辑和审稿人的评审意见，我们需要“修改后重投”（Revise and Resubmit）。修改后重投是编辑和审稿人给出的指示，告诉我们他们希望对论文做出哪些修改。如果你做了这些修改，他们就会再次进行审阅，并决定这篇论文是否达到了该期刊读者的质量和兴趣水平。作为这次修改后重投的一部分，其中一位审稿人提出了一些我并不同意的意见。为了表明
my level of disagreement as I was going through the paper, you know, we often use these headings when we respond to each reviewer, and it will say, for example, responses to reviewer 1, 1's comments. And I changed the heading to responses to reviewer 1's random musings and terrible requests. And two of my co-authors on the project just laughed and regreed with my complaints as I went through. So I could see in the word doc that I would make a complaint or a comment about the viability and often stupidity
我在通读论文时对这些意见的不同意程度，你知道，我们在回复每位审稿人时经常会使用一些标题，比如“对审稿人1的意见的回复”。而我把标题改成了“对审稿人1的胡思乱想和无理要求的回复”。在这个项目中，我的两个合作者只是笑笑，并且在我逐一浏览时附和了我的抱怨。所以我可以在Word文档里看到，我会针对这些意见的可行性，甚至是愚蠢程度，
of some of these comments. And they would add their comment, I agree, this is a terrible comment. I can't believe that they are making this request. Have they? Is this a first year PhD student making these requests? And we just played off of each other. And then one of my co-authors who I've worked with multiple times, and I love working with her partially because of what she did next, her comments then said, you're right.
写下我的抱怨或评论。他们则会添加他们的评论：“我同意，这是一个糟糕的评论。我真不敢相信他们会提出这个要求。他们是吗？这是一个一年级博士生在提这些要求吗？”我们只是在互相调侃。然后，我的其中一位合作者——我和她合作过多次，我很喜欢和她合作，部分原因就是她接下来做的事——她的评论写道：“你是对的。
I could see why you feel this way about this comment. However, let's think about it from a different perspective. Rather than making a bad request, maybe they just didn't understand what we meant. And so let's take it down a couple notches and focus on what can we do to accurately respond to this reviewer. And so as I read through and looked at her reframing responses, I was more easily able to see what that reviewer was asking. And so I had interpreted their comments as unfair and bad requests, but when this co-author reframed for me, I was able to see, actually those are viable requests.
我能理解你为什么对这条评论有这种感受。不过，让我们从另一个角度来想想。与其说这是一个糟糕的请求，不如说他们可能只是没有理解我们的意思。所以，让我们把情绪降温几度，专注于我们能做些什么来准确地回复这位审稿人。”因此，当我读完并看到她重新构架的回应时，我能够更容易地理解那位审稿人的要求。因此，我最初把他们的评论解读为不公和糟糕的请求，但当这位合作者为我重新构架后，我能够看出，其实这些都是可行的请求。
The change that that has when you're writing a revision is huge. You treat the reviewer as a help rather than a hindrance. It changes the tone with which you write. It changes your willingness to go above and beyond to respond to their comments. And ultimately, whenever you're able to do that, it makes the revision better. You know, Mike, as you're talking,
当你进行修改时，这种改变所产生的影响是巨大的。你把审稿人视为助手，而不是障碍。它改变了你写作的语气。它改变了你超越自我去回复他们意见的意愿。归根结底，每当你能够做到这一点时，它就会让修改变得更好。迈克，在你说话的时候，
I'm realizing that there is another element here, which is that when many of us complain, and I feel like I have done this very often and numerous workplaces where I've worked, complaining about people gives you a feeling like you're being a gentick that you're actually doing something about something that's bothering you. But the net effect of complaining often is that you're just stewing in something that happened and you're hearing somebody else too in the same kinds of complaints and nothing actually gets done. Nobody actually does anything with those complaints afterwards. And I think what you're suggesting is that when someone reframes a complaint for us and
我意识到这里还有另一个因素，那就是当我们中的许多人抱怨时——我觉得我在自己工作过的许多职场中都非常频繁地这样做过——对别人抱怨会给你一种掌控感，让你觉得你正在对困扰你的事情采取行动。但抱怨的实际效果往往是你只是在沉浸于已经发生的事情中，你听到别人也在做同样的抱怨，而实际上什么都没有改变。事后根本没有人用这些抱怨去做任何事情。我想你所暗示的是，当有人为我们重新构架一个抱怨并
helps to point away forward, part of what they're doing actually is giving us back the gift of agency, of actually telling us there is something in this scenario that actually is within your power to do. And of course, as that old proverb says, you know, the wisdom lies in knowing the difference between the things you cannot change and the things you can. And of course, once someone tells you, she are something that you can do, it makes all the difference in the world. You've just got to the heart of this whole research project. You nailed it. Is when
帮我们指明前路时，他们实际上是在把主动权这个礼物还给我们，实际上是在告诉我们，在这个场景中，确实有某些事情是在你的能力范围之内可以去做的。当然，正如那句古老的谚语所说，智慧在于知道哪些是你无法改变的事情，哪些是你可以改变的事情。当然，一旦有人告诉你，这里有些事情是你能做的，这就会带来天壤之别。你已经触及了整个研究项目的核心。你抓住了要害。就是当
we are complaining, we are increasing the extent to which we see things with an external locus of control. We are essentially saying, the world happens to me and there's nothing I can do about it. When we talk to somebody who reframes, they're helping us give us that internal locus of control, helping us see that we are an agent, that there are ways to move forward to fix the situation. For me, it's a very empowering experience to hear someone reframe the situation, because now I can do something about the negative experience. When somebody agrees with us, we lose all power over the situation. We have to wait for the supervisor to change
我们在抱怨时，我们正在加剧以外部控制点来看待事物的倾向。我们本质上是在说：“世界对我做了什么，对此我无能为力。”当我们与进行重新构架的人交谈时，他们正在帮助我们建立内部控制点，帮助我们看到我们是有主观能动性的，有办法向前推进并解决问题。对我来说，听到有人重新构架情况是一种非常赋能的体验，因为现在我可以对这种负面经历采取行动了。当有人同意我们的看法时，我们失去了对局势的所有控制力。我们不得不等待主管改变，
for things to get better. But when it's reframed for us, now we can go out and fix the situation. Mike's research shows that when someone voices that complaints to us about a third party, simply agreeing with them may be the easiest path, but it is not the most helpful path. If you really care about the other person, your fundamental job is to help them see the big picture and to see that they themselves may have power to make the problem better. When we come back, a series of techniques that can make us vastly more effective in getting our complaints heard and resolved. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Complaining can affect our emotional states, our relationships, and our work.
事情才会变好。但当情况被为我们重新构架后，现在我们可以走出去解决问题了。迈克的研究表明，当有人向我们倾诉对第三方的不满时，简单地附和他们可能是最轻松的途径，但却不是最有帮助的途径。如果你真的关心对方，你的根本任务就是帮助他们看到全局，并看到他们自己其实有力量把问题解决得更好。接下来，我们将介绍一系列能够极大地提高我们抱怨的有效性并使其得到解决的技术。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。抱怨会影响我们的情绪状态、人际关系和工作。
At Clemson University in South Carolina, psychologists Robin Kawal's key has found that one of the biggest shortcomings in the way we complain is that most of us do it unthinkingly. Robyn and other researchers have developed a taxonomy of complaining. Broadly speaking, there are two ways to complain. Most of us choose the path of what is called expressive complaining. Expressive complaints are literally what they sound like. They're complaints where you are just expressing your dissatisfaction,
在南卡罗来纳州的克莱姆森大学，心理学家罗宾·科瓦尔斯基发现，我们在抱怨方式上的最大缺点之一，就是我们大多数人在抱怨时都是不经大脑的。罗宾和其他研究人员开发了一种抱怨分类法。从广义上讲，抱怨有两种方式。我们大多数人选择的是所谓的“表达性抱怨”。表达性抱怨字面意思就是它们听起来的那样：它们就是你只是在表达自己的不满，
whether you truly feel dissatisfied or not. Think of it as like cathartic complaining. So, I may be driving down the road, and this actually happened to me today. I was driving down the road, and somebody was right on my tail. And that makes me nervous. I'm afraid what if I have to hit the brakes or what if they would hit me. and somebody was right on my tail. And that makes me nervous. I'm afraid what if I have to hit the brakes or what if they would hit me.
无论你是否真的感到不满。把它想象成发泄式的抱怨。所以，我可能在路上开车，这其实今天就发生在我身上。我正在开车，有人紧跟在我的车尾。这让我很紧张。我担心万一我得急刹车怎么办，万一他们撞到我怎么办。所以我对那个人产生了一些抱怨。
So I'm having some complaints about that person. Now, that's not going to change their behavior. They can't hear me. I was not gesturing. I was not complaining that way. But it's not going to change that person. It did make me feel better, though. It made me feel better to just be able to express because it was making me tense,
这不会改变他们的行为。他们听不到我说话。我当时没有比手划脚。我不是那样抱怨的。但这不会改变那个人。不过，这确实让我感觉好受了一些。能够表达出来让我感觉好受些，因为刚才那让我很紧张，而在车里发几句牢骚减轻了我的紧张感。所以，这是发泄式的抱怨，即使它不会带来任何实质性的改变。但事实证明，还有另一种更有效的抱怨方式。它被称为“工具性抱怨”。而另一方面，工具性抱怨
and it reduced my tension to be able to just mouth off in the car. So that's, it's cathartic complaining, even if it's not going to bring about any substantive change. But it turns out there is another way to complain that is vastly more effective. It's called instrumental complaining. instrumental complaining on the other hand, though,
是旨在带来非常特定结果的抱怨。所以，你知道，我对有线电视公司总是有些抱怨。他们处理我的电视，他们处理我的网络，所以总是有这样那样的问题。我必须对此抱怨。但如果我想对此采取点行动，我可以去向邻居抱怨，而她用的是完全不同的服务提供商。所以她对此无能为力。但这其实对我没有帮助。
is complaining that's intended to bring about a very specific outcome. So, you know, I always have complaints about the cable company. They handle my TV, they handle my internet, and so there's always something. And I have to complain about. But if I want something done about that, I could go complain to my neighbor about who has a totally different service. So it's not like she can do anything about it. But that's not really gonna help me.
那将是表达性抱怨，但那无法解决问题。如果我想解决问题，那么我需要进行工具性抱怨，打电话给公司说：“听着，我的网络又断了，电视坏了，电话也坏了。”这就是工具性抱怨，我对抱怨的性质非常有目的地进行控制，以便带来非常特定的结果。这些不同类型的抱怨在有效性上有什么区别吗？
That would be expressive complaining, but that's not gonna fix the problem. If I want the problem fixed, then I need to engage in instrumental complaining, call the company up and say, look, my internet's out again, the TV's not working, the phone's not working. That's instrumental complaining where I'm being very intentional about the nature of the
你知道，这是一个很好的问题。这完全取决于你的目标是什么。你知道，如果你觉得，我只是需要发泄一下。我只是需要一吐为快。那么发泄一下是挺好的。但如果你的目标是，你知道，修好有线电视，那么你采用表达性抱怨是不会奏效的。
complaint in order to bring about a very specific outcome. And is there a difference in the effectiveness of these kinds of complaining? You know, that's a great question. It really depends on what your goal is. You know, if you're, if what you feel is, I just need a vent. I just need to get it off my chest. The venting is going to be fine. But if your goal is to, you know, get the cable fixed, then you're not going to be effective
所以这确实取决于你的目标是什么。我了解到你和其他人做了一些研究，探讨了这两种抱怨形式的区别以及它们对幸福感的影响。你发现了什么，罗宾？是的，我们在幸福感方面发现的第一件事是，幸福感与抱怨之间存在着反比关系。这具体体现在“令人恼火的小事”（pet peeves）上，这些是非常非常具体的抱怨。
engaging expressive complaining for that. So it really does depend on what your goal is. I understand that you are, and others have done some research looking at the difference between these two forms of complaining and the effects on happiness. What do you find Robin? Yeah, so what we found with happiness is first of all that there's an inverse relationship between happiness and complaining. And it was specifically in terms of pet peeves which are like very, very specific complaints.
在一项研究中，罗宾和她的同事让人们列出他们对伴侣感到不满的小毛病。罗宾发现，虽然几乎每个人都对自己的伴侣感到恼火，但最幸福的人表达抱怨的方式却有所不同。你抱怨得越多，你的幸福感就越低。然而，在那项研究中，我们还研究了“正念”（mindfulness），你可以把它理解为真正关注
In a study, Robin and her colleagues asked people to list their pet peeves with a significant other. Robin found that while most everyone had annoyances with their partner, the happiest people expressed their complaints differently. The more you complain, the less happy you are. However, in that study, we also looked at mindfulness, which you can think of it as really paying attention to
或意识到你的抱怨。我们认为，有正念的人会更好地调节自己的抱怨。这并不是说他们不抱怨。这并不是说他们不表达令人恼火的小事，而是他们在抱怨时非常有策略。这让他们能够有效地抱怨，同时又不会对他们的幸福水平产生太大影响。这是我们在节目中以多种方式探讨过的一个想法。情绪可以是一种触发因素。
or being aware of your complaining. What we think is that people who are mindful sort of modulate their complaining more. It's not that they don't complain. It's not that they don't express pet peeves, but they are very strategic in how they go about complaining. And that allows them to effectively complain while not affecting their happiness levels as much. It's an idea that we have explored in many ways on the show. Emotions can be a trigger.
我们感到愤怒，我们发牢骚。但情绪也可以是一个信号。我们不是立即反应，而是可以问自己：这个信号在告诉我什么？我该对此做些什么？罗宾列举了一种将触发因素转化为信号的技术。威尔·鲍文发起了一场名为“无抱怨世界”的运动，他有这些紫色的手镯。把它想象成那种“坚强活着”（live strong）手镯，它们就像那样，上面只写着
We feel angry, we mouth off. But emotions can also be a signal. Instead of immediately reacting, we can ask ourselves, what is the signal telling me and what should I do about it? Robin cites one technique to turn triggers into signals. So Wilbo and who started a movement, if you will, call the complaint free world, he has these purple bracelets. Think of it as, you know, like the live live strong bracelets, they're like that and they
“无抱怨世界”。他背后的想法是，养成或改掉一个习惯需要21天。所以，你知道，威尔说如果你抱怨了，你就应该把手镯从一只手腕换到另一只手腕，然后你的21天就要重新开始。我认为手镯本身并没有什么魔力，除了它能让你在抱怨时意识到这一点。然后你相应地调整你的抱怨。我的隔壁邻居是一名心理健康咨询师，在她以前工作的地方，她的一位同事在婚姻咨询中使用了这些手镯。所以，什么婚姻咨询？每个伴侣都必须戴上手镯。然后，
just say complaint free world on them. And his idea behind it is sort of like it takes 21 days to make or break a habit. And so, you know, Will says that if you complain, then you should switch the bracelet from one arm to the next and you start your 21 days over again. I don't think there's any magic about the bracelet per se except for the fact that it makes you aware when you complain. Then you modulate your complaining accordingly. My next door neighbor is a mental health counselor and at the place that she used to work, one of her colleagues used those bracelets in relationship counseling. And so, what marriage counseling? So, each partner had to wear the bracelet. And then,
当他们抱怨配偶时，他们就得把手镯换到另一只手腕上。再说一次，这并不是手镯的魔力，而是手镯起到了提醒的作用：“哦天哪。”而且，如果你不想一直把手镯传来传去，那么，你知道，你就会减少你在那种特定情况下对伴侣关系进行抱怨的频率。减缓情绪触发的另一种技术是把它们写下来，而不是说出来。写日记可以让你慢下来。
when they would complain about their spouse, then they would have to switch the bracelet to the other wrist. And again, it's not the magic of the bracelet, except the bracelet serves as a reminder of, oh my gosh. And, you know, if you don't want to keep slipping the bracelet back and forth, then, you know, you're going to decrease the frequency with which you complain in that particular case about your relationship partner. Another technique to slow down the trigger of emotions is to write about them instead of talking about them. Journaling can slow you down.
写作迫使你阐明自己的想法。写作的慢节奏能让你观察自己的情绪、描述它们，而不仅仅是凭情绪行事。罗宾发现，把你的抱怨写给惹恼你的人，这种方法尤其有效。与其去联系那些可能倾向于一味附和你的第三方，不如把你的抱怨写信给冒犯你的人，
Writing forces you to articulate your thoughts. The slowness of writing allows you to observe your emotions, describe them, not merely act on them. Robin has found it especially, effective, to write your complaint to the person who has upset you. Rather than reach out to a third party who might be inclined to merely agree with you, writing your complaint to the person who has offended you
这可以帮助你调节自己的反应，因为你无法夸大自己受到的伤害有多严重。在一项研究中，罗宾对比了三类人：写信向惹恼自己的人表达抱怨的人、向第三方分享抱怨的人，以及写一些中立事情的人。我们发现，当人们在信中直接向当事人表达不满时，他们在随后的评分中实际上表示，他们更喜欢那个人，他们认为那个人也更喜欢他们。
can help you modulate your response since you can't exaggerate how badly you were injured. In one study, Robin compared people who wrote complaints to a person who upset them, to people who shared complaints with a third party, and to people writing about something neutral. What we found is that when people express their dissatisfaction in a letter directly to the person, they actually said the in the ratings afterwards, they said that they liked that person more, they thought that person liked them more.
而且他们对自己与那个人关系的评分，比另外两种情况下的评分都要高。这又回到了我们之前讨论过的正念。我认为当人们在写一封他们认为另一个人会看到的信，并且在信中表达对那个人的不满时，我们的表达方式是不一样的。
And they rated their relationship with that person higher than people in either of the other two conditions. And it goes back to what we've talked about with the mindfulness. I think when people are writing a letter that they think another person will see and they're expressing their dissatisfaction about that person, I think we articulate it differently.
你知道，我会仔细表达我的感受，我对外的不满。如果你这样做了，如果你进行了那种有正念的、有意识的抱怨表达——也就是说你对此非常有策略——那么你就会在事后体验到更多积极的结果。罗宾曾有机会运用她学到的
You know, I'm gonna express carefully what I feel, what I'm dissatisfied about. And if you do that, if you engage in that mindful, intentional expression of your complaints, so you're being very strategic about it, then you're gonna experience more positive outcomes following that. Robyn once had a chance to apply what she has learned
关于工具性抱怨的知识。公寓大楼的经理需要把押金支票退还给她儿子，但却一直拖延。押金支票本该在30天内退还，但押金支票一直没有寄到。所以我只是顺路去了一趟，我说：“你知道，30天已经过去了，你知道，是时候拿到押金支票了。”他的回答是：“支票在邮寄途中了。”这真是一句经典的台词。我说，我说：“哦，支票在邮寄途中了？”
about instrumental complaining. The manager at an apartment complex needed to return a deposit check to her son, but was holding out. The deposit check was due back within 30 days, and the deposit check did not come back. So I just went by there and I said, you know, 30 days has passed, and you know, it's time to get the deposit check and his response was, it's in the mail, which is such a classic line. And I said, I said, oh, I said, it's in the mail.
我说：“那我大概什么时候能收到呢？”他说：“大概从现在算起两周吧。”我说：“好吧。”我说：“那么如果到那时我还没收到，我该怎么办呢？”因为我知道，我知道根本不在邮寄途中。所以他说：“那，那你再过来一趟，或者你知道的，你给我发邮件。”于是我说：“好吧，我的办公室就在附近。所以你可以指望我还会回到这儿来的。”
I said, well, when should I expect to receive it? And he said, like two weeks from then. And I'm like, okay, I said, well, when I don't receive it then, I said, what should I do then? Because I knew, I knew it wasn't in the mail. And so he said, well, then, you, well then you come back by or you know, you email me. And so I said, well, I work just down the road. So I said, you can count on me being back here.
当然，支票根本不在信里。所以我确实给他们发了邮件。我说：“我姑且相信你这一次。把那张支票作废吧。我今天会顺路过去，你可以重新开一张支票。”于是他在大约半小时内就回信了，他说：“支票会为你准备好的。”好吧，很好。
Well, of course, the check was not in the mail. And so I did email them. And I said, I'll give you the benefit of the doubt. I said, just cancel that check. And I'll be by there today and you can write a new check. And so he wrote back, like within a half an hour and he's like, the check will be waiting for you. And, okay, good.
所以，工具性抱怨在带来期望的结果方面非常有效。[♪ 背景音乐播放，并在南卡罗来纳州克莱姆森大学探讨抱怨的科学。罗宾，非常感谢今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。]《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷莱、罗恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。
So, instrumental complaining can be very effective in bringing about desired outcomes. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in and the science of complaining at Clemson University in South Carolina. Robin, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick.
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。对于今天的无名英雄，我们把话筒交给你们——我们的听众。这是一个来自我们的节目“我的山吉拉”的故事。今天的节目来自南卡罗来纳州辛普森维尔的贝茨·考克斯。2014年9月，贝茨和她的丈夫史蒂夫迎来了他们的儿子布莱克。他们家当时没有太多钱，住在一个可能会有点冷的小联排别墅里。所以有一天，在布莱克出生大约九周后，贝茨把他绑在汽车安全座椅上，开车去了当地的沃尔玛购买一个空间加热器。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's unsung hero, we turn the mic over to you, our listeners. It's a story from our show, Myan Sanghira. Today's story comes from Betsy Cox of Simpsonville, South Carolina. In September 2014, Betsy and her husband Steve welcomed their son Blake into the world. Their family didn't have a lot of money at the time and they lived in a townhouse that could get a bit chilly. So one day, about nine weeks after Blake was born, Betsy strapped him into his car seat and drove over to her local Walmart to pick up a space heater.
那是那种感觉处处艰难的寒冷早晨之一，我进门时情绪低落、有些慌乱。当时我是一位新手妈妈。所以，你知道，可能有点烦躁。当然，我走到加热器货架区，发现他们的加热器也卖光了。所以我本来就已经有点暴躁，希望今天能过得顺利一点。于是我走到其中一个清洁用品过道，也就是海绵之类的地方。突然，这个男人
It was one of those first cold mornings where everything felt like a struggle and I came in just kind of down Tratton flustered. I was a new mom at the time. And so, you know, just maybe kind of irritable. And of course, I went back to the heater section and they were also out of heaters. So I was already just, you know, kind of cranky and wishing that the day was going differently. So I made my way over to one of the cleaning aisles, the sponges and stuff. And all of a sudden this man just
大步向我走来。他是一个南方人，非常开朗，几乎就像圣诞老人一样。他身上有一种超乎寻常的强大气场。他说：“朗达（呼唤他的妻子），你得来看看这个宝宝。我们能来看看，我们能来看看这个宝宝吗？”他的口音非常讨人喜欢，他说他有一双最大最美丽的蓝色眼珠子，我从没听过有人这么说话，这让我咯咯笑了出来，而且立刻改变了我的情绪。所以我们聊了一会儿，他在最后说：“上帝对你真好，亲爱的。
came booming towards me. So he was a southern man and had a very jolly like presence, almost like Santa. And it just kind of a larger than life dynamic to him. And he said, Ronda, calling out to his wife, you've got to come see the baby. Can we come see the, can we come look at the baby?" And so his accent was very endearing and he said he has the most big beautiful blue eyeballs and I just never really heard someone say that and it just made me chuckle and kind of immediately shifted my mood, you know. So then we chatted a little bit and he said at the end, God was good to you, Darlin.
上帝对你真的太好了。”他说这话时充满了激情。这几乎把我惊呆了。我简直无法解释。这只是一个奇妙的人类连接时刻。它是如此简单。而且也很奇怪，因为在我从这个男人身上稍微回过神来之后，
God was real good to you. And he said it with such passion. It just about knocked me over. I can't hardly explain it. It was just this amazing moment of human connection. It was so simple. And it was so strange too, because then after I kind of got over being slightly awestruck
我甚至冲进了好几条过道想再看他们一眼，但他们就像“砰”的一声消失了。然后当我走出来时，阳光明媚，我抬头看着天空：这个男人是谁？他让我感觉太棒了。而你会记住人们带给你的感觉。我知道他那天就是特意被放在那里的。这听起来可能很疯狂，但我能感觉得到。上帝对我很温柔，我非常感激。就在那样一眨眼的功夫，他改变了我对那天整天的看法。他影响了我的生活。
from this man, I even went darting down a few aisles to get another look at them and they were just like poof gone. Then as I came out and it was a bright sunny day and like I just like looked up to the sky like who is this man? He just he made feel so good. And you remember how people make you feel. I know he was put right there for me that day. It's crazy, is that my seam or sound, but I just, I can feel it. God was very good to me and I'm so grateful. And just in the length of an eye like that, he changed my whole outlook of that day. He impacted my life.
所以我想对他说一声谢谢。他对我来说真的是一个无名英雄。南卡罗来纳州辛普森维尔的贝茨·考克斯。当我们采访她时，布莱克七岁了。朋友和家人因为他具有冒险精神而管他叫“伟大的布莱克”。如果你想帮助我们制作更多这样的故事，请现在就行动。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org，加入其他数百位《隐藏的大脑》听众的行列，向我们展示你们是我们的后盾。
And so I just want to say thank you to him. He's truly been an unflanguero to me. Betsy Cox of Simpsonville, South Carolina. When we talk to her, Blake was seven years old. Friends and family call him Blake the Great because of his adventurous spirit. If you would like to help us build more stories like this, please act now. Visit support.hiddenbrain.org and join the hundreds of other hidden brain listeners who have showed us they have our back.
再次访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回头见。这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vidantum. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是商卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。